be welcome back to the show uh once
again an important victory for you and
this was against an opponent who was
quite uncomfortable for you in the past
how are you feeling right now and give
us your story of these games and its
critical
moments hi guys thank you very much so
in the past I wasn't able to somehow bit
Anna especially us Champs it's just like
it doesn't go my way and today after the
opening I was thinking okay most
probably uh will have an equal position
and it's end in a draw or something like
that but after she played Knight E5 I
had High Hopes somehow I feel like she
spent so much time and she
couldn't uh she couldn't dive in when it
was like diing into the position and
think when she actually had to and she
started to make faster moves because she
had only 20 minutes or so yes so I think
I D5 is a mistake it's just letting me
develop all my pieces and then Rook is
coming to C2 and I I I have a feeling
she forgot after Queen C3 actually E6 is
never a threat because Knight F6 uh
always covers the king that's right
there was this last moment when she
could have played it a bit more actively
with the move Bishop to C3 this was
perhaps absolutely her best
chance but uh I think she didn't see
what to after C5
C5 can you
take you can take yeah
but I'm not winning anything right here
so I have to play slow right right
probably not C5 just because there's
also Queen to C7 coming in the position
and if you do defend that maybe I can
just get out of this pin yeah probably I
would just play King h8 or something I
would think about it I wasn't sure what
she would play yeah uh B C3 is very nice
uh unfortunately I don't have C5 anymore
that's what I actually blundered I I
felt like I was winning the game until
uh I I saw that actually Bishop C3 I
don't have much yes and then Bishop C1
is C5 because I'm protecting the pawn
yeah no after C5 it feels like you're
once again building up your advantage
and she actually doesn't have any uh
counterplay against your king your king
is perfectly safe on
F7 yeah and she took and then it was
this moment when she tried this Hail
Mary with Knight to B3 maybe you will
take on B3 but after your last move
Queen to E5 that just pretty much
finishes the game The Rook is under
attack I was just very surprised I was
very surprised by Bishop C1 I feel like
she had something but uh I couldn't
figure what she had so I I totally
forgot Bishop C3 C5 is not working it's
like check on C7 to that was a critical
moment I thought okay I thought like
okay let's put the Rook on C2 now she
has to decide what to do and then I will
just think about the position after so
maybe it wasn't as good as I thought it
was maybe well isine this is still a
very important victory for you with only
three rounds to go uh it's uh looking
good and kissa's game is still very much
unclear go enjoy your rest day get ready
for the last stretch of the event and
we'll see you in a couple of
days thank you so much guys absolutely
our congratulations as well bam as we
just uh